hi there Steve Kaufman here frequently
asked questions on language learning and
this is the second in a series of three
on this whole issue of do i memorize the
case standings in Russian or the verb
endings and of course it has application
for other languages in the first video I
talked about how while the general
concept that endings / verbs or nouns
may change the specific explanation of
you know why or what happens in which
situation if it's masculine feminine
different cases and so forth it's very
difficult to grasp and remember
similarly with the issue of of the you
know subjunctive and so forth until we
have had a lot of exposure to the
language now obviously if you're going
from spanish to portuguese you
understand the concept so that in fact
reading those explanations is very
helpful and you pick up on how you know
Portuguese is different from Spanish so
that's not the same i'm talking about
going to a language which has new
concepts that you don't have in your own
language it could be a sale Russian
speaker learning English and all the
explanations about when to use the
article and not to use the articles are
very difficult to retain to understand
entertain in my view now the second part
of this series then is how do I deal
with the ex what endings themselves and
of course in Russian you know I can go
to my table like this and there's lots
more tables and they choose certain
representative nouns in masculine and
feminine and neuter or it could be verbs
and typically you have your regular
verbs and irregular verbs or nouns and
there would be two or three types within
each you know gender and stuff like that
I have found it very difficult to study
from these tables but I still do it I
will do for example I'll review the
table I when i'm reviewing tables or
lists i'm looking for relationships what
tends to happen regardless of the sample
type of non what is there that's in
common I try to review these tables I
have
within link i will save for example all
the nouns that end in ooh because the oh
might be accusative singular it might be
the dative singular in the masculine or
E or e might be you know there are three
or four perhaps situations where this
ending occurs so I tried saving tagging
them for these endings and reviewing
them in the vocabulary I also tried
tagging by dative instrumental whatever
prepositional case and reviewing them
and then reviewing the actual tables and
I found that the the results are not
tremendous that you do a lot of sort of
short term learning and if you leave it
for two days it's all gone so I don't
say that it's not helpful I think it's
part of the picture it helps you notice
but it's it's not enough it's not enough
it doesn't help to groove those those
neural networks in your brain and and I
now look back on it and I think that I
probably wasted a lot of the time that I
spent trying to nail down the endings
even if you memorize them and you think
you know you've got them and it is a
quite a tall order to memorize because
they vary from gender to gender & and
there are exceptions and stuff still to
actually try to use them on the flywheel
you're speaking is very very difficult
and as I say all of the things that I
tried to memorize in this manner it
seems to me that like I think I'm
learning more than than I am in fact
learning so I don't spend a lot of time
on the tables on the endings themselves
but I do occasionally review them I keep
it you know for a handy review and I
have a couple of minutes here and there
but never with the expectation that I'm
going to nail them down it's just a
little bit of a refresher that hopefully
helps me remember those endings so I
will stop there and the third one is I
will talk about where I think I finally
am making some progress in
of recognizing these endings and being
able to use